by balancing liquid light and air 3d  printing technology is getting smoother  and faster the new process is called  continuous liquid interface production  or clip for short other printers put  down one solid layer at a time in a  lengthy mechanical process clip works by  projecting a series of ultraviolet  images through a special window located  below a bath of liquid resin the light  causes the resin to harden into the  projected shape like a series of  solidifying movie frames as the printed  object is lifted out of the bath fresh  resin is pulled toward the window 3d  printing is now a continuous process and  the speed is mainly limited by how fast  the resin cures and its viscosity  you